I got my merch on do you have your merch
on we're about to watch the Rocky movies
talk about some of the health effects
that my man Rocco has faced let's get
into it people
hey yo Rocco
I never understood why boxers did this
back in the day or frankly any athletes
I can't help but think about salmonella
falling into his cup right now because I
bet those are not pasteurized in Shell
eggs he doesn't look like he was fancy
enough to be buying those and salmonella
you can go many eggs without getting it
I think the statistic is one in 20 000
eggs contained salmonella but that one
time you get it you're gonna wish you
did it also I believe that there's a
fact out there eating raw eggs decreases
your ability to absorb biotin which is
good for hair skin and nails
on your shirt guys
this is so unnecessary not only is he
punching raw meat that should be used
for human eating consumption but he's
also punching ribs hurting his knuckles
because he doesn't have boxing gloves on
as any boxer would know an injury to
your knuckles is an injury to your
boxing career potentially
I'm breaking the ribs
also he's throwing punches and kind of
like a weird form I don't know what that
is he's not like throwing a straight
shot he's not throwing a hook he's kind
of like doing some kind of in between
overhand thing
those wraps smell like that
I want to grab the same beanie on except
mine's merch link down below to sign up
for the new merch release coming soon
you lay off that Pet Shop game
women we can lay a scientific accuracy
of that statement just has never been
proven to be true whether you look at
hormone levels you look at performance
it just there is no pattern that has
emerged there and I'll tell you why
because I don't think it's women I don't
think it's sex I think it's the act of
getting boozed up stressed out staying
up late that's what weakens the legs but
it's not the women or the sex that's
causing it I call misinformation on that
one
get him on the speed bag
yeah Rocco
[Music]
that's actually really hard there's an
element of Plyometrics there shoulder
strengthening core strengthening a lot
of stuff is happening there this is
really impressive
core training for boxing is so important
because not only are you needing the
ability to absorb hits but you also need
the ability to turn your body that's how
you develop strength in boxing
[Music]
can someone get this guy a proper
punching bag the cows need a break
[Music]
that kind of exercise on the stairs is
obviously the iconic Rocky moment and
while I think stairs are a great
exercise I think it trains your lower
body extremely well your cardiovascular
system extremely well I prefer doing
like the Aero bike to that because
you're getting an upper and lower body
workout and a hit workout at the same
time
all right
your nose is broke nasal fractures are
very common injury especially in boxing
40 to 50 percent of facial fractures
happen in the nose but two things can
happen you can form a septal hematoma
which is blood pooling in the area
causing immense pressure problems and it
actually needs to be drained and then
the second thing that could happen is
you could have a fracture of your
cribiform plate where you actually start
leaking cerebral spinal fluid also known
as CSF
right body shots are brutal because not
only do you have the potential for
breaking someone's ribs which obviously
is extremely painful hurts your ability
to rotate hurts your ability to breathe
but also because your liver is there and
a shot to the liver with its unique
position within the body and its unique
relationship with the nervous system and
the circulatory system a shot to the
liver will bring you down I can't see
nothing gotta open my eyes
[Applause]
this is such a terrible scene okay so we
no longer do this What's Happening Here
is he has a hematoma over his eye
swelling blood pooling and essentially
he's saying cut her open so the fluid
can leak out and I can actually open my
eye and see that was done incredibly not
safe he didn't even disinfect the area
first that's going to be a problem
nowadays this is not legal cut men are
not actually cutting you they're
actually stopping your cuts from
bleeding and gauging on whether or not
the cut is dangerous to the person's
life or vital organs come on
training then torturing a poor chicken
running around there's just there's
exercises you can do where you don't
need to chase a chicken my husband and I
thank you for coming to our training
quarter today well hello my fellow
Russian immigrant I'm glad to face you
if there have been rumors of blood
doping and widespread distribution of
anabolic steroids in the Soviet Union
has drego partaken in any such
experiments no anabolic steroids blood
doping it is a real thing in
professional sports even though there
are steps put in place to prevent it
like drug testing Russia also had a huge
scandal with anabolic steroids I highly
recommend there's a documentary on
Netflix called Icarus definitely check
that out because it just shows you how
dirty and nasty all of these games are
behind the scenes
[Music]
averages
1850 pounds so the result is quite
obvious
that he's strong what is the technology
have to do with it this guy didn't
describe anything it looks like he
created those arcade things that you see
on Tick Tock videos of people failing
and hitting the top of him breaking
their hands no
wow
oh yeah the reason the referee has to
come in and step in or the coroner has
to throw in the towel is because the
fighter no longer can make decisions for
themselves if you take too many punches
to the head it's very easy to find
yourself in that position so if you see
a fighter that just getting hit
repeatedly repeatedly not being able to
throw back not being able to show that
he's doing any kind of movement or
action that puts his life in jeopardy
that's where he gets shut down and
stopped
what's interesting is that a lot of the
deadly blows and most damaging blows in
boxing come over a period of time
multiple blows over over again not like
that one strong knockout that actually
ends up knocking you down and there's a
lot of problems when it when you start
having bleeding in the brain because the
skull is an enclosed environment there's
nowhere for that blood to go so if the
person starts bleeding a they're not
getting blood flow to the actual part of
their brain that's necessary but it also
starts building up pressure putting more
pressure on the brain essentially
shutting parts of the brain down if your
brain stem shuts down the part that's
responsible for respiratory rate or
cardiac rate that shuts down that's when
you die if he does he does
Rocco where the chest compressions
you don't know why he's dying what if
he's bleeding internally he needs some
chest compressions check his pulse Rocco
I guess that guy is roiding but it's not
clear what that was and earlier it was
mentioned blood doping blood doping is
basically either getting transfusions of
blood either from yourself or from
someone else or they give themselves a
chemical known as EPO erythropoietin
which is actually a chemical made by
your kidneys that increased the
production of red blood cells thereby
increasing your oxygen carrying ability
Russians cut
kind of a weird way to say it
that last punch was so fake it was bad
like he just went like this and nothing
even happened and there was the sound
effects
[Applause]
boxing actually has this 10 count right
there's a person who stands outside the
ring and actually starts the count and
holds the count also once a fighter is
up it doesn't necessarily mean they're
ready to fight if the referee deems that
the fighter is not able to protect
themselves like if the referees like
move left move right hold up your arms
in front of you if you're unable to do
that that means you're unable to protect
yourself the fight is still over
[Music]
I can't
stop my hands from shaking I mean maybe
it's a good time to go to the hospital
I'm just tired I just
want to go home okay at this point there
should be a ring physician or ringside
physician coming in doing a neuro check
making sure that neurologically he's
intact he's fine he's stable and I don't
feel like that's happening here recently
the American Medical Association
recommended that boxing be banned yeah
do you agree with the doctor is boxing a
dangerous sport that is unhealthy for
your brain yes is there a way to
practice boxing practice boxing not
actually fight and be healthy yes in
fact there's a lot of healthy benefits
to boxing when you're calculating
someone's risk in their life you're not
just looking at one activity there's a
lot of variables those who step inside
the ring and risk getting hit in the
face and cause CTE to their brain
they're taking a risk I think it's their
choice I think a lot of people make that
choice you know absolutely I I think the
doctor should never fight no say that I
shouldn't fight Rock I'm sorry buddy but
I gotta do it because of the continuous
violent blows to the Head you've
developed a condition particularly to
boxers called cavem septum folliculum
which is a hole in the membrane
separating the ventricles the brain
surface neurons in this area have also
been traumatized I don't even know what
the heck they're looking at here it says
physical there's some kind of beautiful
lines there's different cuts that we're
looking at here maybe a functional MRI
like an early one the reality is the
condition they're talking about is one
that has been Associated not proven to
have happened with contact sport
athletes Fighters football players Etc
it's been associated with CTE chronic
traumatic encephalopathy we have tied
the condition to worse mood outcomes
worse scores but it's also something
that can happen during development and
be an incidental finding and sort of
like a normal variant on Imaging so
there's still a lot of questions to be
answered what causes this exactly how
does it happen because there's only
theories out there so far and what are
the implications if it does happen if
you've never had it before and in fact I
know in the future uh Rocky movies he
goes back to fighting so clearly this
wasn't a reason for him to retire I
think want to like do something like
what
fight
[Music]
I don't know that you need to squat 10
plates in order to be a box
and he loves his raw eggs my man just
get some whey protein powder it's
ridiculous
[Music]
the tears bicep by doing that
[Music]
oh my God he's punching the cows again
just God
the effects got better but not much
better
[Applause]
another Fighter's bone with a bad angle
is very problematic elbow you go to hit
a body shot the elbow hits you in the
thumb and the wrist could potentially
break your hand hitting someone in the
hip bad angle can turn the wrist sprain
it break it another one is on the skull
you go to punch a fighter they tilt
their skull down it flexes your wrist
like this over flexes it potentially
sprains tears breaks bone here
how's the hand my hands bro how's the
head my hands broke that's it throw in
the fight there's no need to continue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
forward Ah that's not exactly true
boxing is the sport of hitting and not
getting hit
Rocco was not the only boxer in the
house this doctor is a boxer too click
here to check that out as always stay
happy and healthy click here check it
out
who else you know who can box it in
office chair huh